[Music]
on this Tuesday night alarm over El Nino
the warning about the weather phenomenon
warmer Waters in the ocean will mean
warmer air masses on the land plus the
climbing costs of climate change
political popularity a new poll finds
the federal conservatives gaining ground
bitter about Twitter smells blood in the
water with Elon Musk and Twitter being
weak and the new competitor coming
online this week plus where there's a
will there's a Norway this is the time
for us to consider where we go the tiny
Scottish archipelago that wants to
brexit and reconnect with its Nordic
roots
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Jeff Semple good
evening and thank you for joining us
Monday officially marked the world's
hottest day ever recorded with global
temperatures reaching an average of
17.01 degrees Celsius that surpassed the
previous record set in 2016 according to
the U.S centers for environmental
prediction and more records are expected
to fall this year with heat waves on the
horizon
here at home millions of Canadians are
in the midst of a multi-day heat wave
that sparked warnings and special
weather statements for much of Ontario
and Quebec they could last until
Thursday with the humidex in some spots
topping 40 degrees severe thunderstorm
warnings also covered parts of Southern
Quebec with 50 millimeters of rain
falling in Montreal in a single hour
this afternoon the story is similar
South of the Border tens of millions of
Americans are under extreme weather
warnings with thunderstorms and intense
heat and today the United Nations
weather agency warned of record heat and
dry conditions in the coming months as
Eric Sorensen reports El Nino has
arrived
as hot as the last three years have been
they've been moderated by La Nina cooler
currents in the Pacific but we are
entering an El Nino year and the World
Meteorological organization is worried
this is the result of rapid and
substantive change both in the
atmosphere and in the ocean El Nino
water that warms up the Eastern Pacific
is reappearing for the first time in
seven years El Nino warms the atmosphere
and coupled with climate change
scientists expect records to be broken
if not this year perhaps 2024. what we
know is that throughout the next five
years we are likely to have one of the
warmest year on Oracle the World
Meteorological organization established
a baseline for surface air temperatures
in the world between 1993 and 2009 and
with that Baseline for what's normal
this is the forecast for the next three
months above normal temperatures in red
blanketing almost the entire planet from
Europe to Death Valley in the northern
hemis sphere where most people on the
planet live the summer heat is now
sweltering stick a thermometer in the
planet you see global fever warmer
Waters in the ocean will mean warmer air
masses on the land and so this is what
is in store for planet Earth this is the
global precipitation forecast now till
September for North America drier than
normal in the U.S Southwest and in
Northern Ontario and Quebec where dry
conditions have already seen wildfires
burn more forests and other lands than
ever before as is typical this time of
year a heat wave has descended on
Ontario and parts of Quebec some beat
the heat by hitting the beach at Sunrise
we're looking forward to because I think
it's really hot we're going to go in the
water get a little cooler for others
there's no joy in the prospect of
increasingly hot weather this is not
going to stop
and it's existential the World Health
Organization now expects the global
temperature will exceed 1.5 degrees
Celsius above pre-industrial levels
sometime in the next four years well
they're going to keep Rising until we
stop emitting carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere so we are ex we're emitting
more than we ever have been it's not
entirely clear how El Nino and climate
change interact but the last strong El
Nino year was 2016 and that year was the
Earth's warmest on record Eric Sorensen
Global News Toronto
the tornado that tore across central
Alberta over the weekend was the most
powerful to hit that province in decades
researchers have raided the Twister an
ef-4 out of five on the enhanced Fujita
scale that makes it one of the most
powerful tornadoes ever recorded in
Canada with just 21 others reaching that
level and the strongest tornado to hit
Alberta since Edmonton's monster twister
back in 1987 a preliminary report shows
Saturday's tornado packed wind speeds up
to 275 kilometers an hour with a track
620 meters wide a dozen homes were
damaged but incredibly no one was
seriously hurt
those Alberta homeowners joined the
growing number of Canadians now
struggling to rebuild after devastating
extreme weather events Heather York's
West reports on the growing costs of
climate change
in central Alberta disastrous scenes
when we came in view of the property my
wife just broke down crying and then we
could see literally everything was gone
in less than 30 minutes the tornado
destroyed Decades of memories rebuilding
will take time and money the victims of
This Disaster far from alone last year
was three billion dollars in Damages
we're probably going to be in that range
again two to three billion dollars of
insured losses in this country
across Canada it has been a devastating
few months storms floods and the worst
Fire season the country has ever seen we
know insured losses are less than a
third of total losses for households or
for businesses because beyond the
property loss there is also a price for
the Emergency Response in responding to
the wildfires over to municipalities and
metis settlements have had to manage
extraordinary costs and pressures to
help keep residents homes and businesses
safe on Tuesday the Alberta Government
announced a 175 million dollar program
to help communities recover some of
those funds but if the last few years
have taught us anything there will be
more events ahead it's now time for
governments uh at all orders
municipalities provinces federal
government to work very collaboratively
together to invest in Risk reduction
across the country changing building
codes constructing fire breaks and
bringing in a national rating system to
help Property Owners understand their
climate vulnerability are all things the
Insurance Bureau of Canada says
governments need to prioritize now
major Investments That economic models
suggest could see returns 15-fold with
more and more extreme weather events
ahead Heather York's West Global News
Calgary
more than a dozen fire crews are dousing
hot spots from a huge warehouse fire in
Winnipeg a vacant building went up in
Flames early this morning after a series
of explosions the fire torched an area
the size of a city block and choked the
neighborhood with thick smoke the fire
department says the building was used
for storing tires and may also have
contained vehicles and fuel
well there appears to be no resolution
in sight for the BC Port strike
negotiations have stalled after four
days and the strike is already taking a
toll on the economy
the retail Council of Canada says more
than one billion dollars of cargo flows
through West Coast ports every day that
accounts for an estimated 25 percent of
Canada's imports and exports and as
nithu garcha reports there could be
serious consequences for small
businesses too
[Music]
workers are Marching outside one of
their employers Vancouver dispatch
centers their union says they're
fighting for long-term labor stability
needed in the industry
they're among more than 7 000 workers
who load and unload cargo at more than
30 BC ports the union has highlighted
three main concerns at the bargaining
table automation Contracting out and
cost of living wage increases the
bottlenecks at Terminals and warehouses
are growing ports are clogging up with
cargo stuck on Shore businesses are
scrambling to find Alternatives we have
small and medium-sized retailers who
have containers that are stuck behind
picket lines at container terminals who
want the contents of those of those
containers to sell to customers in their
stores Greg Wilson with the retail
Council of Canada says if the strike
continues for a few weeks there could be
layoffs in other parts of the supply
chain including distribution centers and
transport companies all consumers bear
those costs the Vancouver Fraser Port
Authority says one of every three
dollars of Canada's trade and goods
outside of North America moves through
the port of Vancouver so any disruption
to Port operations has a significant
impact globally and on Canadians this is
going to hit affordability for Canadians
and Canadian businesses immediately so
we need to see this uh taken seriously
and we'd like to see the government
recall Parliament and start working on
Back To Work legislation there were
similar impasses on the U.S West Coast
earlier this month President Joe Biden
and the new acting U.S Secretary of
Labor stepped in to help broker a
six-year contract it still shows
collective bargaining Works negotiations
hit an impasse overnight and by Tuesday
Morning the BC Maritime employers
Association said talks had paused
calling on the union to put forward what
it calls a reasonable proposal to reach
a fair and balanced deal federal labor
Minister Sheamus o'regan's office said
they were quote pleasantly surprised to
see the employee lawyer didn't directly
ask for Back To Work legislation and
encourages both sides to remain at the
bargaining table until they come to an
agreement but the longer this drags on
the more pressure Ottawa faces from
business groups to step in and help
ensure a deal is reached Jeff Garcia in
Vancouver thanks Nieto
the federal conservatives appear to be
gaining ground with a slight lead over
Justin Trudeau's Liberal Party according
to new ipsis polling conducted for
Global News 37 percent of Canadians said
they would vote for Pierre paliev's
conservative party if a federal election
were held tomorrow that's a four-point
jump since February Mackenzie gray digs
into the details
Canadians are getting no perks from this
government it's the Breakthrough the
conservatives we're hoping for pear
polyev increasing his lead over the
liberals who were stuck in second place
with 32 percent support nationally well
this is the first time we've really seen
the conservatives open up a meaningful
gap between themselves and the Liberal
Party since the spring of 2019 according
to the latest ipsos poll done
exclusively for Global News the
conservatives would win a large majority
of the seats in Alberta Saskatchewan and
Manitoba and in Ontario they're tied
with the Liberals at 38 percent
pauliev's message on affordability and
housing seeming to land in a province
the Tories need to pick up seats in if
they hope to form the next government I
think on housing in particular like
you're seeing that crunch really acutely
in the GTA despite the rising numbers
the conservative vote has traditionally
less efficient compared to the Liberals
as shown in the last two elections where
the Tories got more votes overall but
the Liberals handily elected the most
MPS the prime minister Minister hoping
for a similar outcome in the next
election he holds a solid lead in
Atlantic Canada and in Quebec where
they're in front of the block and 22
points ahead of pauliev the conservative
party really isn't present in terms of a
popular vote in the province of Quebec
so they're holding on to the Liberals
are holding on to that the NDP are a
distant third with only 16 percent of
the vote but jugmeat saying is hoping
Progressive voters are looking for
change I think it's an opportunity in a
change election to show that in a time
where Canadians are really having a hard
time that this government only acts
because you can meet and the NDP are
forcing them to act Singh is also doing
well in British Columbia where he's
polling second ahead of Justin Trudeau
and it's likely up to the NDP leader on
when he wants to test that support at
the polls by pulling the plug on their
deal with the Liberals Jeff
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks Mac
MPS of all stripes are calling for
Urgent reform of the federal access to
information system the law empowers
Canadians to request Federal records
including government reports and
invoices in the name of transparency but
as our chief political correspondent
David Akin reports critics warned the
system is broken
[Music]
concerned citizens want answers on the
federal response to wildfires
a business wants to know why it failed
to get a government contract a
researcher wants government data on
vaccine safety each should be able to
get answers from Ottawa using access to
information or ATI but the ATI system
that tens of thousands of Canadians turn
to every year is badly broken what we
see is institutions are afraid of
providing information there's a culture
or secrecy at the government level the
federal department of citizenship and
immigration gets more requests by far
than any other department more than 200
000 people last year used ATI to get
information about their immigration case
the department was singled out by the
information commissioner in her recent
annual report for poor ATI performance
the real solution is going to be going
upstream and proactively sharing
information with applicants to come to
Canada about their files so they don't
need to go to the access to information
route in the first place meanwhile the
information commissioner's office was
swamped last year with more than seven
thousand complaints about delays and
failures to provide requested
information and we every year the number
of complaints increases the timelines
are increases as well the commissioner
asked Justice Minister David lametti for
an extra six million dollars to hire
investigators to clear the backlog of
complaints lametti refused the request
we brought access to information reform
earlier in our mandate or continuing to
watch how how it goes
there is there are there are always
improvements that could be made and will
continue to look at them still dozens of
times over the last decade information
Commissioners and parliamentary
committees have called for Urgent
overhaul of this broken tool of
government accountability and little
ever gets done to fix it Jeff all right
David Aiken in Ottawa thanks David
a new social media platform is going
online coming up why some are calling it
a Twitter killer
welcome back Facebook and Instagram's
parent company meta is preparing to
release its answer to Twitter threads
rolls out in Canada on Friday around 10
million Canadians use Twitter according
to the company but the app has been
plagued by controversy and meta is now
looking to capitalize Zan gaviola
explains meta's so-called Twitter killer
is already raising concerns about
privacy
there was Much Ado About an online spat
pitting Elon Musk against Mark
Zuckerberg in a cage fight but the
biggest Showdown will be in the hands of
social media users later this week
smells blood in the water with Elon Musk
and Twitter being weak at the moment
Zuckerberg's meta the company formerly
known as Facebook will roll out threads
a social media platform some are already
calling a Twitter killer others have
taken on Twitter Blue Sky Mastodon and
Trump's truth social but meta has
something other Rivals don't this really
is a case of a deep pocketed competitor
outlasting a competitor whose pockets
are literally empty it'll be interesting
to see because Elon Musk can certainly
uh open up additional funding sources
but he's already made it clear he's
pretty Tapped Out Twitter's new CEO
Linda yaccarino has been awfully quiet
since taking the helm ad revenue is down
some 60 percent since the musk era began
and threads allows users to access their
insta Network you're not starting your
network from scratch that is the killer
advantage and that's likely the reason
why threads will succeed where the
others have failed but privacy has
always been meta's Achilles heel Twitter
founder Jack Dorsey among others
pointing out meta's access to your
financial and fitness stats browsing
history and other sensitive info but I
think if you look at the likes of tick
tock and Twitter and any social platform
in terms of their what data they use and
how they use it and you know that
they're all fairly similar you're seeing
a lot of desperation and you're seeing
them throughout a lot of innovative
products that aren't catching on to the
public because uh basically they are
becoming more and more irrelevant to how
people use social media some say the
battle of billionaires apps is a symptom
of our Collective social media fatigue
and gaviola Global News Toronto
displaced by disaster still ahead
flooding in China forces thousands from
their homes
severe flooding triggered by Heavy Rain
is inundating parts of Southwest China
footage from the state broadcaster shows
rescue Personnel assisting in
evacuations more than ten thousand
people have been forced from their homes
so far no deaths have been reported
the United Nations has approved Japan's
plan to release treated radioactive
water from the damaged Fukushima nuclear
plant into the ocean
after a two-year review the
international atomic energy agency says
the plan aligns with global safety
standards and the health and
environmental impact would be quote
negligible groups in South Korea and
China oppose the move no date has been
set to start the release of the water
but the process is expected to take 40
years to complete
in Israel at least nine people were
injured in an attack in Tel Aviv
Israeli officials are calling it an act
of Terror the attack happened today
after Israel launched a large-scale
incursion into the occupied West Bank
today's attack was captured on security
cameras they showed the 20-year-old
suspect driving a pickup truck into
pedestrians before jumping out and
stabbing a man Israeli police say the
attacker was Palestinian he was shot and
killed
[Music]
breaking up with Great Britain next the
island that wants to swap Scotland for
Scandinavia
foreign
the United Kingdom has seen huge
political upheaval in the past decade
Scotland almost voted to leave in 2014
then brexit saw it split with the
European Union well now there's
Rumblings of another divorce a small
Scottish archipelago with historic ties
to Canada wants to get in touch with its
Scandinavian Roots Redmond Shannon
explains
there are few places in the UK as
idyllic as orkney at least when the sun
shines it's a group of 70 Islands
sitting just off the north of Scotland
and home to 22 000 people but there is
currently a little trouble in Paradise
we don't seem to be getting the same
amount of resource even as the other
Islands after brexit and the fight for
Scottish independence now orkney's
Council has voted to look into saying
goodbye to both Scotland and the UK at
least in the way it is governed one
option for orkney would be to become a
self-governing British crown dependency
like the Isle of Man or Channel Islands
I went along the street and spoke to one
or two of the people they were saying
this is the time for us to consider
where we go how we can really contribute
to a global world the islands were once
the main recruiting hub for Canada's
Hudson's Bay Company and there are now
even suggestions arcadians could look
far afield again to embrace their strong
Viking Heritage as a territory of Norway
I mean just look at their Flags the
names of our places but the names of our
people are very nice for example they're
popular names for children would be
Ireland
um thorfin we celebrate Norwegian
Constitution Day then the 17th of May we
have a talk got a parade lots of friends
from Norway come to that orkney was
Norris territory until
1468 when the king of Denmark and Norway
gave the islands to Scotland as a dowry
for a royal wedding Professor Donna hedl
thinks the threat to return is more
about political leverage it's difficult
to see um first glance what the
immediate benefits of such a change
would be a spokesperson for British
prime minister Rishi sunak says there is
no mechanism for orkney to change its
status but the fact that he's had to
respond could be a sign The Arcadian
proposition is already working Redmond
Shannon Global News London
and that is global national for this
Tuesday night I'm Jeff Semple tonight's
your Canada is the buck Moon captured
from a soyuz British Columbia it's the
first Super Moon of the Year meaning
it's closer to Earth than normal and
appears bigger and brighter than a
regular full moon you can catch it
tonight too thanks for watching hope to
see you back here again tomorrow have a
great night
[Music]
thank you